une enquête la draft nba on sait c'est
beaucoup d'incertitudes mais pour
certains joueurs il faut carrément jouer
au détective pour évaluer le niveau et
c'est très rare mais cette année un
potentiel top 10 est un peu un joueur
mystère il est canadien il s'appelle
sheridan sharp il n'a plus joué de match
officiel depuis l'automne 2021 nous on a
été chercher des matches on vous propose
son profil dans ce podcast ça va être
explosif et puis on fera une deuxième
partie plus courte sur un autre canadien
mystère léonard miller il pourrait aussi
s'inviter à la fête le 23 juin prochain
la date de la draft shannon sharpe
léonard millaire deux canadiens aux
contours flous enquête génériques
tu
ce
les enquêteurs ce soir à la manu ben
salut les gars
et un invité aussi pour approfondir
c'est thomas vous le connaissez
peut-être sur twitter il a le pseudo az
cas et je connais pas à suite de ça
c'est samba salut à tous merci à toi
d'être ici thomas grand plaisir de
t'accueillir ont invité car tu as la
particularité de regarder beaucoup de
basket ball près nc n 6 et et avant la
fac ce soit au lycée soit dans des
compétitions un peu spéciale on rentre
pas dans le détail mais vous donc vous
tous messieurs vous êtes allé dénicher
des matchs pour évaluer ses joueurs
avant de tirer le portrait de shannon
sharpe vous vous posez peut-être la
question vous qui nous écoutent et
comment est ce qu'un joueur peut avoir
le droit de se présenter à la draft sans
forcer sans passer par là ancien ou la
g-league alors que la règle du london
elle est censée être toujours en vigueur
allen est ce que tu peux nous éclairer
en fait c'est une question c'est plus
une question d'âge est une question de
année de diplôme plus qu'une année de
plus qu'une histoire d'éligibilité
annuel post-bac équivalent post-bac
choses comme ça fait qui a été fait
ce qu'on appelle le one donne donc d'au
mieux et 2000 les gens pensent c'était
pour plus qui est de passage de lycée à
haïti et direct à une vieille à ce qui a
été fait c'est qu'on a l'âge d'entrée à
l'egypte et la draft on l' a reculé un
peu ce qui faisait que voici les joueurs
voulaient se faire voir dans les
derniers mois qui précédaient la
possibilité d'aller à graver fallait
qu'ils aient à la fac pour de facto
pouvoir jouer ce qu'ils avaient déjà
souvent eu leur diplôme au lycée est
ensuite allé six mois pour certains ou
l'année entière fallait bien qu'il la
fasse quelque part qu'en fait ça arrange
lnc qui récupérer des fortes allant
s'arranger et une vie aussi parce que ça
ils pouvaient les voir dans un contexte
comme celui des anciennes donc avec un
joueur comme celle de sharp les gens
disent comment il peut faire il a jamais
joué en cfa il aurait pu jouer à initier
parce que
c'est un joueur qui a graduate
attente dans les temps en réalité pour
pouvoir jouer initiés pouvoir aller à la
draft et puis c'est un choix personnel
aussi de pas avoir joué parce qu'il
aurait pu jouer là durant le second
semestre de la saison 2021 2022 il était
sur le banc accueilli comme un joueur
comme hamidou diallo avait fait durant
l'année 2010 16 2017 sauf qu'il a décidé
de pas jouer pour certaines raisons
absolument on y reviendra donc la règle
il faut être dans l'année de ses 19 ans
avoir validé son diplôme depuis un an
c'est le cas donc de shade sharp arrière
assez grand pour sa position va parler
de son physique un peu plus tard mais
qui sait déjà ce gars qu'est ce qu'on
sait de lui ben tu as fait tes petites
recherches talus t'as vu ta écouter sur
lui
ouais bah ça fait un petit bout on
inventa par radio-canada ça fait depuis
depuis
2009 où il
ya eu size et
traîner l'équipe sur ses épaules il vous
montre et c'est alain
l'a montré cet alain en display
devant tout le monde puis il est monté
vraiment sur les sur les radars de
toutes les équipes américaines et son
nom sa candidature a pris de plus en
plus d'importance avec les
les reclassification des mots ni bates
et c'était kg petit cercle a fait
exactement il est devenu le numéro 1 de
facto de sa classe
monsieur
dallo on s'aimait
mais
voyez c'est ça donc donc il vient de
london en ontario il a 18 ans il va
avoir dîné le soir de la draft une
rumeur folle qui courent sur internet
comme de shannon sharpe qui l'animent
attendu dans l'ancien joueur de foot
américain et l'animateur d'une émission
complètement infecte à fox dont j'ignore
le nom roudou sa combi
indiscutable où il s'engueule avec skip
bayless pendant ou font exprès
s'engueuler lui ce qui est bayless mais
c'est faux ce n'est pas le fils de celle
de shannon sharpe si vous voulez trouver
l'information c'est sur le site web de
kentucky son père s'appelle robert
tschopp sa mère s'appelle giulia belle
et c'est un couple sans histoire de
london en ontario qui est une ville
plutôt sans histoire aussi qui pour un
des épicentres du basket au canada et
mélie le honnêtement je dire les gars
vous l'avez vu le même si c'est un
garçon sans histoires qui vivait en
plein milieu d'un champ en saskatchewan
il y aurait des cultes et le c'est
vraiment une histoire
puis ce jeune garçon très terre-à-terre
quitterait s'il ya le genre de mentalité
whisky c'est qui est meilleur que tout
le monde sur le terrain et je sais que
chez les france les fans de france juin
les sourcils à cette mentalité parce que
ils s'imaginent que le joueur est
arrogant mais pour joie des livres c'est
très important d'avoir cette mentalité
là il parle de son de son jeu comme est
un jeu similaire à celui de bradley bio
et
d'evenko que ce qui est profond ce qui
est peu fou du tout je crois qu'il y en
a un qui n'est plus apte lundi même
parle tu veux dire pardon lui même parle
de son jeu comme ça en disant similaire
habile exactement mon la demande de
décrire son jeu puis ya donné il ya
donné ses étalons de comparaison la pour
l'instant il est un peu plus athlétique
que les deux je crois me est encore
beaucoup plus jeune donc moi je trouve
ça très
très sain qui avait pas répondu quelque
chose comme kobe ou quelque chose du
genre quelque chose de demeurer dans ce
genre là je trouve qu'il ya une bonne
comparaison pour son style de jeu donc
il a déclaré à la drache droit sinon
aksoy l'a
abandonné son éligibilité à kentucky et
il va
il va d'après moi hype lundi trois ou
quatre
bras des projections après il a déclaré
sa pré candidature il y a peu de temps
il a gardé son éligibilité ans pour tous
né à kentucky a wish âge mais ça fait
peu de doute qu'il sera candidat au
grand désarroi des fans de kentucky j'ai
eu pas mal d'articles là-dessus qui
parle notamment de son mentor qui
s'appelle dwayne washington qu'un peu
manipulé tout le monde en disant qu'il
n'irait pas à la draft etc
on l'a vu jouer donc en uc l on disait
avec team canada alan ou est ce qu'on
l'a vu jouer d'autres shannon sharpe et
on parle de quelle leur rôle dans ces
contextes quel type de joueur moi je les
veux jouer dans trois comtés différents
donc eu 16 canada où ben laden l'a dit
c'est pas vraiment le leader pour moi
c'était il était un peu en complément du
duo donc rail a mené mardi caleb houston
ryan n'est marqué lui cinq sont aussi
deux de freshman qui deux initiés qui
étaient les leaders aussi de tim yeux de
team canada aux u19 l'été dernier que
sharks n'a pas fait pour des raisons que
j'expliquerai dans deux secondes il l'a
pas fait parce que sharp a fait la
saison qu'on appelle la saison et ybm
2021 et c'est à cause de cette saison et
waibel 2021 qu'il a acquis les montées
surtout les rangs king et qu'il avait
vraiment sa cote est vraiment en flèche
et donc la yohimbine comment pour
expliquer ça c'est un genre de l ue
régionales c'est un petit peu du tout ce
que les scouts européens des tests au
premier abord alors il ya comme je
l'avais expliqué du négatif du positif
mais toujours est il que pour certains
prospects c'est parfois intéressant de
les voir dans ce contexte là écharpe
dans ce contexte cela a été vraiment
extrêmement impressionnant on a vu un
joueur qui était capable comme l'a dit
ben d'exceller sur le pouleuf d'exceller
dans la finition au cercle et je pense
tout le monde l'a un peu dit alors le
littorail ybm
web os 2 3 un peu plus deux porteurs de
balle qui était l'initiateur ce qui ne
l'était pas du tout en 8 16 est-ce qu'il
était donc un eagle est ce qu'il était
henri school de 3e contexte je les ai
vus nos cadres inc à
l'arrivée en arizona dream christian
academy oui je vois avec le français
yohann traoré d'ailleurs les c'est un
peu les deux gros prospects de cette
équipe et où il était aussi porteur de
balle
en fait c'est intéressant il a commencé
à 16 ans plus la chair of ball et en
fait quand il a commencé à vous grandir
et a gagné d'ex la dextérité balle en
main dans le circuit un peu américain il
a vraiment commencé à être porteur de
balle excellé sur le poulpe finir en
altitude tout ce qui fait qu'il est
aujourd'hui pressenti au pas ce que
pense la chair ça fait moins rêver car
en sortir
absolument on a effectivement vu jouer
le film existe ce n'est pas un joueur
complètement mystérieux alors ça
ressemble à quoi sur le parquet manu est
ce que tu peux décrire les qualités
principales on va dire ce qui saute aux
yeux
mais ce qui saute aux yeux c'est un
joueur super athlétique on voit d'emblée
dès qu'il a le ballon il saute super au
super vite donc ça c'est celle un
téléski le principal après aussi le
shooting qui est super impressionnant
comme le diadème sur l'ibis est
clairement révélé là dessus
sur sa dernière saison à aix cool aussi
la 43% à 3 points et les les stades qui
espionnent donne 35 % sur 107 104 107
tentative mais pas trop après sur quoi
ex-base exactement sur ces sur ses
tentatives est ce que c'est tout ce
qu'il a fait donc les trois comtés dont
on a parlé ou s'il ya autre chose ou
s'il ya un peu moins ne sais pas trop là
dessus
et ce qui saute aux yeux si c'est si les
outils défensif donc il est peut-être
pas forcément toujours
dedans en défense où il peut laisser des
forts penser qu'il n'est pas dedans
qu'il n'est pas intéressé à la défense
me l'a dit super utile défensif pour
pour saïda douki l'annoncé à 1,98 de
mètres pour une envergure à 2 10
donc ce qui est immense etc c'est
vraiment l'un des skills pour malossi
qui potentiellement qui peut le faire
devenir un joueur
impressionnant et comme kiva qu'il va
gagner six minutes en nba grâce à ça
effectivement c'est ce que tu avais noté
sur son sur ton scoot in report qui est
sur notre site 1,1 point c'est au vous
voulez vous pouvez vous le mettre sous
les yeux en écoutant la deuxième partie
de ce podcast ce qui est pratique
donc pour en revenir à ça avec la nba
c'est que on peut plus facilement
évaluer le niveau de la compétition
thomas toi thomas toi qui regarde
beaucoup de matchs donc or n 6 et
comment on va jauger le niveau de ces
compétitions le niveau des adversaires
de celle de sharp en fait aux réclamants
c'était delahaye school donc ça restera
entre il est plus facile de performer
c'est le cas de nombreux joueurs mais il
a quand même affronté du vrai beau monde
sur sa dernière année en high school il
a frotté des problèmes comme êtres
humains base vegas élite wasatch
académie où ça allé plusieurs fois en
prolongation que des biais des vrais
matchs serrés avec de la bonne intensité
de la défense correcte sinon lors du
galet qu en octobre et l'affronter du
très gros postpaid du mike williams donc
voilà il ya du très très lourd il avait
joué trois matches peut également citer
le meilleur joueur de la compétition
assez largement on voyait qu'ils jouent
assez tranquillement on peut lui
reprocher ça il ya un loup qui joue un
peu un peu en marchant parfois on voyait
vraiment qu'il y avait sept cette
domination au niveau du talent sur tous
les genres qu'il a joué voilà il avait
joué du maïs il avec le prolifique prep
avec déjà quand même gerais très white
démo n'a donc il est vraiment vraiment
de la belle opposition au niveau high
school il a montré que c'était le genre
dominant dans chacune de ces et match up
lors du viie bielle également en tant
que tueur porteur de balle il a été je
crois les lieux donc pas le meilleur
joueur je crois de la compet s'est
rendue du très très lourd et il a tout
simplement pas dominé la concurrence eu
assez assez tranquille où on va dire est
ce que ces équipes ont gagné au niveau
du haut niveau du de l'ice croûte qu'un
état de santé déficient ça me semble
être une équipe peu plus tôt plutôt
avril face aux grosses cool ça faisait
ça faisait des victoires et des défaites
ce n'est pas une équipe sur dominant ce
n'est pas une équipe nulle ou grâce à sa
partage lé score paraît you guys gauche
c'est qu'il avait gagné assez largement
compte my team et sa partage est plutôt
les scores et pareil avec eux ils
étaient couplées canada hyundai canada
en haïti y duel est pareil c'était
plutôt une équipe
dans la tranche dans la tranche moyenne
mondiale il n'était pas dans la phase
finale du web elle qui s'appelle le
pitch diam yes man legends qui avait été
gagné par l'équipe de design du règne de
mémoire et de
mai en fait il n'était pas dans vraiment
des équipes avec 3 4 méga prospère lui
était le meilleur joueur d'une équipe où
il était un peu plus tout seul quoi donc
je demandais parce que certains scouts
avec qui on a parlé disent qu une stat
et souvent pas assez observées aux mises
en avant c'est la colonne victoires
défaites tout simplement c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant de savoir si tu es
dans un environnement où ça gagne sa
paire et puis comment ils se comportent
en fonction la question la question
maintenant parle d'un top 6 top 8 i/s
pnt athlétique est ce que vous vous êtes
déjà tous dans ce mode là ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour le mettre aussi au
charme brad hawpe c'est ce même plus en
terrain de 26 locke
son potentiel il top 5 ok on rappelle
pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi sur cette
draft 2022 on a le troupeau de tête
l'échappée chat en grain paulo bancaire
au jabbari smith 2 certains y ajoutent
des navy sharp serait donc juste
derrière ce groupe en tout cas chez les
scythes mainstream la question qu'on se
pose ce soir et ce qu'il mérite de faire
partie de la conversation pour intégrer
ce premier groupe ce groupe de très haut
niveau ça va être notre débat on parle
dans ce groupe de tête de chat en grain
protecteur de serre quasi générationnel
ou deux joueurs pouvant à terme en tout
cas ayant le potentiel pour être leader
ou excellent second couteau banque
queiros mise voire à et vit dans une
équipe qui marche donc est-ce que celle
de sharp a ce potentiel là il a les
compétences pour mener ou être un des
leaders offensifs d'une attaque nba qui
fonctionne bien c'est ça la question
être le leader technique
et surtout à ce moment ci de sa carrière
un profil athlétique absolument
incroyable mais ce que j aime de lui
c'est que justement ces mouvements
atlantique lors qu'on les voit on les
voit pas c'est pas que je suis quelqu'un
qui sait courir et sauter cci fait
athlétiquement il est impressionnant en
fait en situation basket c'est à dire un
des trucs qui est vraiment très très
fort à faire ces cris de la séparation
avec avec son épaule ou avec un style
qui eux qui eux ce qu'ils physique qui
ôte qui très très rare d'avoir à ce
niveau là c'est un style que caringo
aussi c'est la capacité d'arrêter net
sec en transition c'est extrêmement
difficile à face n'est pas d'équipé de
jouer au basket le sait que dans
situation de transition on va faire à
peu près quatre mois après avoir arrêté
lui il est capable d'arrêter trentenaire
qui est capable d'écrire la séparation
lâché hunting avec n'importe qui sa
section foot works est absolument génial
en situation de tir il explose dans sa
mécanique boum puis donc je voudrais que
techniquement parlant il ya une courbe
d'amélioration qui peut monter jusqu en
haut du tableau vraiment très très
facilement mais que les situations
simples
lit ça va être déjà très très dur pour
des défenseurs d'un billet de le garder
sur la hanche
les fondations sont solides
la dalle écoulé que j'avais lundi dans
le bâtiment absolument
je pas si les gars vous êtes d'accord
mais moi juste que j'ai vu je trouvais
ça dont on va demander à tous mais
qu'est ce que tu as à dire sur le bagage
technique handle pas si noir au rythme
ce qui me dérange un peu les seuls
points que j'ai négatif chez le trou
sont en deuil quand même assez assez
moyen il est couplé au fait qu'il n'est
pas non plus un premier pas élite élite
je ne sais pas on n'est pas dans la
tranche de challenge green par exemple
c'est clairement en dessous je trouve ou
même de jaden ivy donc je trouve qu'il a
pas cette île a pas cette facilité
encore comme comme un green a passé
ultra facilement son défenseur couplé à
son haendel moyens c'est le seul truc je
pense qu'il peut avoir un corps un petit
peu de deux mâles en situation de cuir
enlever un à attaquer attaquer son
défenseur et et finir au cirque sur un
pivot derrière c'est le seul truc que
j'aurais à redire sinon et serein pour
s'arrêter pour couleurs c'est vraiment
très très fort il crée bien de la
séparation comme benaddi il est vraiment
très costaud également donc il peut
mettre des petits coups d'épaulé
également il arrive bien à se détacher
de son défenseur mais voilà c'est juste
sur le congo premiers pas plus haendel
qui a amélioré un petit auprès de encore
plus plus fort plus explosif vers le
cercle c'est intéressant allen est ce
que tu es d'accord avec thomas sur
l'explosivité sur le premier pas je suis
assez d'accord mais c'est pas grave je
pense qu'il faut se rendre compte que
john green et des de naïve et orange en
europe ce sont des athlètes
plus plus plus on a peut-être banalisée
mais un peu la tête que pouvaient
challenging parlement l'année dernière
sur le premier pas tout tout ce que ça
pouvait enchaîner et influer sur son jeu
je ne cherchais un peu plus il l'est
moins dans la halle et le changement
d'appuis brutale que ces jours là il est
plus dans le catégorie de plus dans la
catégorie smooth trouve balle en main
mais comme ces jours là il a peut-être
aussi un problème de haendel mais c'est
pas d'un joueur qu'est né en 2003 donc
les un joueur qui a toujours été un peu
plus athlétique que ses adversaires
qu'ils pouvaient toujours un peu leurs
shoots et dessus surtout qu'il a
vraiment un niveau de choc making depuis
un an et demi qui est extrêmement en
constante amélioration est très positif
je pense que oui en deuil je suis
d'accord c'est pas son point fort formé
comme des certains joueurs n'étaient pas
d'un point extrêmement important de leur
jeu à la rai par une bille et puis ils
ont travaillé et puis avec de la
répétition ça s'apprend sur le premier
pas aussi d'accord mais en fait comparer
le pont en prépa avec john gray nous ou
déjà séoul où dieu de lévis et oui mais
c'est pour comparer avec des gens qui
sont de rester top 3 4 on comprend
l'argumentaire aussi ouais c'est clair
mais c'est pour ça peut-être que c'est
pour un jour du tir un séjour du tiers à
2 sur sur le fait que son premier pas
lui permet pas peut-être à terme d'être
cet initiateur numéro un d'une attaque
nba qui sera peut-être plus un deuxième
garde extrêmement axée sur le scoring
très fort là dessus la balance va
peut-être se faire là dessus entre sur
la on sait tous que shannon charge
pensera bonne attaque en nba je pense qu
on peut le dire je pense que ça sera
sûrement un bon attaquant nba la
question sera c est ce que grâce à angel
grâce à la vision grâce aux premiers pas
ce que ça peu d'ouvrir d'autres choses
en somme alors sur la vision sur le
passing peut lire les mots de match
schmitz dies fiennes qui a eu l'occasion
d'assister à des entraînements cette
saison à kentucky qui a donc vu jouer
sharp plus récemment que nous tous il
écrit sa date de février il écrit que la
lecture de jeu de shannon sharpe est en
forte progression que son jeu de passes
et même un peu sous-évaluées en parler
les observateurs non seulement donc il
réagit bien ce que propose la défense
qui est une bonne nouvelle parce qu'à
kentucky on n'est pas sur des défenseurs
plots 1 c'est plutôt athlétique agressif
et schmidt il écrit aussi ça c'est
intéressant qu'on commence à le voir
avec des lectures avancé alors
maintenant l'autre grande question c'est
comment le comparer avec jayden ivy qui
est aussi un arrière qui est très
explosif qui jouait à purdue comment on
le classe au niveau des arrières de
cette draft shedden sharp rôle quasi
équivalent même si la vie est peut-être
un peu plus le ballon manu je te pose la
question comment on les compare
je sais pas
c'est difficile question pour que tu me
demandes là
c'est ce que tu les mets dans le même
tiers dans le même paquet huan en jeu
les deux dans le tir 2 mais je pense que
là c'est vraiment joué à la fin pas
l'affectif méo a la préférence du joueur
que va va vouloir le jem président de
l'équipe qui va le racheter parce que il
ya un mec qui est vraiment pour
l'instant plus shooteur donc sharp est
un mec qui est un peu plus créatifs
ultra rapide sur le premier pas qui peut
aller au cercle vraiment facilement être
tenir le contact qu'elle vit
maintenant sur ces sur le potentiel est
ce que je pense que sharp va devenir ce
qu'elle vit ou est-ce que ivy va pouvoir
développer autre chose notamment sur la
défense ou est-ce qu'il a déjà plus ou
moins un plafond atteint son plafond
jeu sur le potentiel je prend en charge
tous les jours
après c'est en fait il s'est un peu
comme je le considère un peu comme
jabbari smith c'est un joueur qui est
capable de d'être potentiellement trop
fort sur plusieurs choses et ça ce qui
est à vie pour moi est bloqué sur fonds
bloqués il est déjà limité sur il est
trop fort sur la taille du panier mais
le shooting j'ai encore des
questionnements parce qu'il a fait une
grosse saison ne suppose l'outing cette
année ou sur les crocs les face au cros
équipe ou six dernières rencontres sur
la saison il est beaucoup plus de mal
notamment donc est ce qu'elle est son
vrai niveau là dessus on avait la même
questionnement sur au sérieuse garlande
par exemple qui avait fait 15 match
exceptionnel à trois points mais l'a
finalement ça se confirme en nba
aujourd'hui sérieuse garlande qui a
plutôt bien répondu aux attentes
donc voilà là aujourd'hui moi je peux je
prends sharp sur sur le potentiel
je le préférant à terme dans quatre
bennes
je t'ai entendu dire top3 tout à l'heure
ou alors justement je sais plus trop non
ouais moi je stocke 3 ça me gênerait pas
comment on fait pour le comparer celle
de sharp à la crème de la crème seiller
smith micro
ss avait pas d une équipe ça dépend de
la vision comme on veut jouer caisse
comptait est-ce qu'on équipiers qui est
déjà bien stocker en termes de grains
est une équipe qui est bien stocker en
termes de créateurs
peut-être en boîte draft c'est sûr que
non probablement par jour déficit je
suis décroît je bave pas
quand je suis détroit que ses troisièmes
jeux doivent pas chez benchmark parce
que je veux un des trois grands
monsieurs qui shoote qui joue très bien
mais on parle aussi de m'en parler du
premier poste que je trouve intéressant
parce que moi je trouve que c'est un
débat qui d'année en année pour air de
la pertinence parce que de plus en plus
de joueurs sont capables de se montrer
comme metal de mineurs au cercle sans
avoir un premier pas d'élite c'est à
dire que depuis les années je lui donne
le cas d'une chute qui ont montré que la
décélération était aussi un homme aussi
patente que l'accélération
fait ça ça m'inquiète pas tant que ça
peut-être le m2 oui mais landau comme du
travail ça se travaille en situation de
match qu'un joueur comme chez job comme
ça ça m'inquiète pas du tout donc pour
moi c'est vraiment un joueur c'est la
joie d'assad draft que je suis plus je
suis le plus
confiant que le ciel est la limite que
qui a pas de limite à qu'est ce qui peut
faire ou à qui il peut devenir je le
vois avec chantôme humaine je le vois
avec fois robert gairaud je le vois avec
du driver avec jabbari ce mythe mais
chez dan church oui une limite potentiel
comme disait à la narbonne attaque un an
et demi elle n'effacera correct mais des
pas tout dépendant de quille et le jeune
homme psychologiquement je peux le voir
absolument défoncer tout les projections
confort lui c'est un risque à prendre
mais si si on veut prendre le risque ce
qui m'intéresse c'est dire si on suit ta
logique site m le premier choix tu n'as
pas de superstar offensive sur les
lignes arrières tu peux le draft est
numéro 1 toi tu dis oui
surtout au château avec avec ce qui
était donné avec
comme enjeu comme angel and green aurait
agi en nba show côté sur le côté
physique qu'au déficit qualité oui été
blessées un point mais la physicalité
était capable a brand puis au panier
ça a pas été constant pour celle en choc
depuis deux ans mais ils ont montré la
capacité de freiner entre trois
défenseurs de ce client de relancer un
vendeur puis d'avoir déçu
le désaxé comme nous comme dirait romain
exactement il a hélas et il a cette
capacité là est une équipe de deux
derniers plans va lui mettre le ballon
dans les mains il va avoir les
répétitions qui le veut parce qu'ils
vont mettre des fesses dans les sièges
je crois que c'est juste un bon c'est
juste du bon du bon business pour
n'importe quelle équipe qui est un top 5
de racheter chez nike déjà pense
particulièrement à orlando qui a
absolument qui crient pour un show voir
depuis des années mais non ces français
venir demain visiblement tu es pas dans
le team ben tu n'as pas charte premier
tiers on rappelle les tirs sont des
groupes de joueurs qu'on estime avoir à
peu près le même potentiel qu'elle tiers
chez toi et pourquoi moi j'étais
justement en pleine réflexion oui
j'avais vraiment de le regarder encore
de plus en plus je me suis retaper des
matches à fond de lui depuis qu'il s'est
déclaré je pense qu'il est vraiment et
j'hésite encore à la rentrée dans le
terrain mais je pense que je vais
rentrer en tire un pourquoi aussi car on
a une ligue quand même dominé par les
extérieurs qui qui poulpe est dans cet
art on en a quand même assez peu le seul
qu'on avait de base c'est un peu de
shenzhen hardy et au final il un peu
flop même si moi je le considère quand
même énormément donc au final la seule
solution la seule grosse solutions dans
le top ten derrière kiprop c c# je pense
qu'il peut garder une très très grosse
valeur et comme l'a dit même si une
équipe veut ça peut ça super star de sa
star offensive
bah elle peut partir et peut partir
clairement sur search et d'un écharpe
très haut donc non je rejoins je rejoins
complètement je pense qu'il peut
complètement repris podium si une équipe
a envie d'avoir le successeur offensive
de sa franchise tout simplement ça c'est
intéressant ça va dépendre évidemment
des besoins des équipes ça fait un
moment qu'on vous le dit on y verra sans
doute plus clair après la loterie à la
nuit pour l'instant on est très élogieux
quand même
gros scoreur athlétique shooter il n'a
pas joué de match officiel de l'année
est ce qu'il ya des équipes alors qu'on
a un top 4 qui paraît clair est ce qu'il
ya des équipes qui vont risquer de le
draft et top 4 alors qu'on n'est quand
même pas sûr de la certitude de
performance ou de compétitivité sont
très bonnes questions en fait on pour
être guirlandes tout à l'heure gare à
lens il avait été pris en 5 mais parce
que c'était un peu une draft à deux
joueurs vainqueurs après derrière bombe
à la fois en fait faut se demander quand
est-ce que via sharks une des plus un
débat pour la france parce que les
autres tops potentiel de la drogue qui
ont été pris et ça va dépendre de
comment ils les classes dans les
franchises mais je pense qu'en fait tout
va dépendre des interviews et des intel
que les éléments qui vont pouvoir
récupérer calipari a été toujours très
positif sur les gens sur twitter quand
on parle avec lui mais pourquoi il n'a
pas joué il aurait dû jouer ils auraient
dû en réalité chez un sharp il avait
tout à perdre à jouer à kentucky cette
année parce que là on en parle comme un
potentiel top six top-5 top 3 par an il
avait il n'y aurait pas pu améliorer son
drive top quoi quasiment un jour bonjour
accueil critique donc c'est normal qu'il
ait pas jouer et en plus il a sauté une
classe donc il est arrivé en cours
d'année et les types étaient l'équipe
était pas formés pour lui l'équipe
c'était l'équipe de tahiti washington et
c'est de servir wheeler avec tous les
transferts kiné qui va se passer donc il
est pas vraiment d'intérêt à jouer donc
cet argument là je pense que les équipes
elles vont pas trop le prendre en compte
ce nom plutôt recherché c'est bah ouais
voilà est-ce que skis comment il se
comporte dans les différents contextes
qu'il a joué
comment il se comporte avec une chute
liée aux entraînements comment comment
ça se passe la cellule familiale et tout
ça donc ça ils vont faire leur enquête
moi je pense quand même que
oui oui dans mon idée que je pense que
chet et bong héros sont soit au-dessus
vêtements dans ces deux genres de mon
terrain
par contre après sharks
jeu drafter échardes devant devant de
vente à barry smith honnêtement et
devant j'ai un petit peu j'hésiterais
avec des danaïdes hésiterait avec jack
griffin que nous on n'a pas mentionné
mais qui pour moi est aussi assez haut
mais c'est ça s'est passé personnel dans
certaines notes qui est un peu plus bas
je pense qu'il y aura les céréales en
tout cas ce genre sur lequel les
enquêtes vont être le plus les plus
fortes sur l'investissement terra le la
cellule familiale et ça mais je pense
qu'on a déjà vu dans le passé que c'est
pas parce que t'as pas joué ici que tu
as joué peu qu on te draft pas comment
la d'idées l'équipe elle et
pour finir là pour finir là-dessus benz
le mentor de shenzhen sharp qui a un peu
entourlouper tout le monde à kentucky il
a il disait il va jouer l'an prochain
c'est sûr dans le même temps il allait
voir les franchises nba en leur disant
vous inquiétez pas il va la draft ce que
savait pas un peu beau papa zaillian
williamson cette histoire
peut-être de tarek mais je crois que je
faisais rien de ce nombre de personnages
et se multiplient autour des jeunes
joueurs depuis 15 ans
je dis ah si j'étais quant à qui je me
serais attendu à quelque chose du genre
le truc c'est qu'ils sont pas attendus à
ça parce que là ce qu'on lit un peu ils
sont assez il avait il n'avait pas prévu
ça pour l'année prochaine quoi et donc
là je pense oui ni non plus sur le culte
à parce que en gros il pensait vraiment
charmant leader de l'équipe avec leurs
deux recrues à côté donc kessen wallace
et
chris liebing stone mais en fait ça va
pas trop se passer comme ça et je pense
qu'ils sont un peu trash là ils ont ils
ont pris un transfert aujourd'hui
en tout cas calipari a dit qu'il
apporterait tout son soutien à sharp
pour le processus pré draft on peut
conclure là dessus on a été un peu long
peut-être sur lui mais bon top 5
potentiel donc ça les vaut ça les vaut
ça les vaut passons à leonard miller
messieurs canadien aussi qu'est ce qu'on
en sait alan physiquement niveau basket
etc dessine nous - les contours
c'est super bizarre parce que je n'ai
pas vu jouer pendant deux ans et la vue
qui s'est remis qu'on en fait qu'on a
t-il annoncé qu'ils pouvaient être dans
la draft ont été oubliés sur congés dans
le dossier parce que lui ont faites
aussi l'été avec sheldon charte et à cet
agrès les amériques du cese alors il
jouait assez peu j'ai retapé des matches
là ça fait bizarre de revoir d'ailleurs
cette équipe de team usa avec jal est
une dure elle un mari bayley adrian et
jack griffin étouffe acéré c'était assez
impressionnant à voir donc il doit le
canada et ben en fait plus on a remué la
risée 15 centimètres de moi qui fais
aujourd'hui l'honneur muller astera
poste de 2,3 de plus 2 qui était tireur
cochet est aujourd'hui la règle et
mensurations restent sont ce qu'elles
sont mais il fait quasiment de 7-2 8 je
pense il est toujours gauche et bien sûr
et 2,8 web est en fait gelé il a joué le
nike hoop summit il ya trois semaines
donc cet affrontement entre les
meilleurs u18 américain et damir u18 du
monde d'hôtes donc de france est dans
l'équipe est un art équipe le monde le
narmer était titulaire au poste 4 dents
et donc qui on l'a vraiment vu pour moi
profil de stretch quatre tireurs
j'ai bien aimé sa capacité à hisser ce
qui il s'est hissé ce que la défense
comment la défense va défendre sur tous
les matches que j'ai vite il comprend
que on sait que c'est un stress fort qui
tire donc quand il ya des clauses out
for sure les caves de poser le ballon
main droite comme à gauche puis ensuite
faire un décalage une attaque bien les
clauses out je pense que c'est un joueur
qui peut vivre en nba sur son tir s'en
sortir mais c'est pas le genre le plus
vu récemment en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il a il ya une croissance s'est
faite depuis deux ans et demi la grandit
il est devenu plus costaud le tir est
toujours là et ça s'est retiré leur
donne tout mais ce que tu valides cet
analyste a vu jouer miller aussi un mois
je le trouve un mois un moins bon que
l'inde sur le tir je trouve il est
encore trop trop irrégulier dans sa
mécanique on voit ses jambes qui partent
par souvent par souvent henry ça se
croient ça se touche assez c'est
vraiment très irrégulier au smic il
avait ajouté je crois qu'il fait il fait
2 sur 4 mais sinon les matchs que
j'avais il ya un ou deux ans était
clairement moins bien même s'il ya une
évolution sa grande taille lui permet de
jouer ce poste 4 moi j'aime bien le fait
qu'il puisse poser la balle avec qu'ils
puissent attaquer les clauses ait si
l'athletic c'est vraiment un c'est
vraiment très intéressant et sa grande
taille sans rappeler un profil de choix
pour la nba je le trouve assez complet
mais encore mais encore vraiment pas mal
boric trouve après les très jeunes ils
avec 18 ans et lequel donc à voir s'il
garde son cette année mais je pense que
c'est un vrai gros seins prospère yards
et peut-être pas pour cette année mais
en tout cas pour l'année prochaine parce
qu'ils peuvent revenir très fort tu
pense qu'il va pas se présenter
finalement bas je suis pas sûr qu'il a
des garanties d'avoir à faire ce pic et
je pense qu'avec tout le talent qu'il a
en faisant une quinzaine d'années un
zidane et high school en soit en année n
6 et pardon ou angelica j'ai vu que les
teintes intéressés par la g-league aussi
notamment je pense qu'il y avait toutes
les qualités qu'il a il pourrait
vraiment faire faire un gros bout sur sa
cote et les attaques avaient fait une
beaucoup plus grosse valeur l'année
prochaine par exemple et il aura
toujours 19 ans et quel tube vrai qu'il
ya des options g-league overtime nba ben
tu l'as vu jouer récemment c'est ça
c'était nec troupes ce mythe j'ai vu la
classique bail au style qui est un peu
l'équivalent du mcdonald's l'american
pauvre le canada il vient d'où la
millionnaire miller il vient d'un
endroit qui s'appelle fort érié en
ontario et il ya une prépa là bas il y
avait tout son art school à la prépare
la baye a vraiment été très discret une
personnalité très discrète aussi un
email mais pour hacher rien sur le ce
que ta mort racontait dans la classique
bail au style juste hama centre
et
y a là rien ils régulent il ya là
il a mis canada tire la plus
divertissante de toute la draft y en a
deux d'un personnage de jeu vidéo qui
lancent des bombes à partir de mi
terrain moi il me dit me il me mais il
me dit très ému il me divertit beaucoup
pardon les annales mais leurs quelque
chose que j'aime bien aussi chez lui
comme dalles en 10 s c'était un poste de
avant et il a le jeu encore c'est un
très bon joueur en transition je sais
que je râle beaucoup confié gens qui
disent qu'ils disent qu'un joueur de 18
ans est bon en tradition mais ce qui
différencie la rhune miller c'est qui
est capable de faire des lectures en
transition et souvent de faire des
changements de vitesse très rapide pour
battre son homme de changement de
vitesse des changements de direction
très rapide pour battre son amitié très
impressionnant pour un gars de son âge
et de sa grandeur aussi parce qu'il est
vraiment et ce jugement du 28 et
c'est vraiment un profil très atypique
très étrange c'est un athlète très beau
trait horizontal sa sauce et l'agilité
c'est la manière de se déplacer plus que
c'est le la verticalité qui est
impressionnante chez lui à la classique
by hostile il s'est fait manger un peu
au bloc il s'est fait bloquer par elijah
fait chez eux entre autres qui est un
autre gros prospects canadien qui arrive
l'année prochaine mais latéralement par
là c'est un gars qui est très très
rapide qui est excellent réflexe puis
justement qui va être un
qui va être avec une équipe qui est
solide défensivement il faut être ferme
être un plus mais qui fera d'aller
chercher des points très rapidement pas
une mauvais passe rarement plus
il ya beau y pas récolté deux passes
décisives dans les classiques bail au
style
gac une vision incroyable c'est un gars
qui fait la bonne la bonne lecture de
jeu toujours un joueur intéressant moi
j'aime beaucoup je suis très heureux
quand j'ai entendu qu'ils testaient le
personnellement j'allais je crois 24e
alors ma nuit ce qu'il a des chances
d'être drafté au premier tour léonard
miller
je sais pas trop si flamur personne je
t'ai vu que nike hoop summit donc après
si sir est je pense et qui sait qu'il a
une promesse de premier tour
parce que trop je vois pas trop
l'intérêt qu'ils auraient de un peu
risqué d'être second tour d'aller de
tomber jusqu'au second tour certes
autant si le potentiel est là comme
comme on a pu le voir autant rester
aussi offert un anti age et d'égout ou
est ce qu'il veut faire et montrer que
c'est vraiment un lot tripes et de corps
et d'aller chercher
la meilleure place possible
tout est apparue légitime ournac loupé
ce mythe par rapport au poste 3 4 de
genre d'événement qui sont généralement
pas loin d'être prospects billets au agi
c'était là honnêtement c'est la première
fois que je le voyais et j'ai vraiment
apprécié le joueur les flashs à la passe
à la création j'ai beaucoup aimé le foot
mais pas rester mais j'ai vu qu'ils
pouvaient foot et donc à voir après ce
que selon ce qui a été dit 6 comment ça
va évoluer après hugh ans ont privé nous
disait qu'il a grandi assez vite et du
coup ça c'est intéressant aussi de
savoir que justement il a joué un peu
plus jeunes avec le ballon et que
maintenant il en a un peu éloigné mais
qui va pouvoir être avoir la balle en
main sur sur quelques séquences donc
c'est mal joué ça c'est intéressant
après j'ai un petit hic sur la taille
parce que moi j'ai vu trois tailles
différentes lui s'annonce à 6 eleven le
hoop summit l'annoncent à 6 nine et
d'ailleurs j'ai vu et 600 alors je sais
pas trop sur quel pied danser là dessus
on va dire de m 7,2 m 8 à peu près est
toujours une fourchette en chaussures ou
pas ça dépend des facs alan tu nous
racontera ça quand tu seras aux usa moi
je pense c'est toujours dans le
moi je pense un peu fait bizarrement on
peut le voir sur la mgmt quand on ya des
fois ci un peu c'est un peu yolo
honnêtement sur les sur les infos qu'ils
sont donnés
20 mais cadencé à 2 mètres au travail de
dix ils font la même taille sur le
terrain puis c'est un peu la volonté du
joueur effectivement
léonard 1000 r la question il vaut mieux
qu'il y aille ou pas alan c'est une
super bonne question je pense que son
profil peut attirer en fin de premier
tour on a déjà vu des joueurs pas faire
une la rareté dont on a parlé pour sharp
et les là aussi un pur miller en termes
de profil est l'élément homme qui en
fait le double argument de l'allée de
l'inconnu et de la jeunesse aussi qui
font que des équipes peuvent se dire
comme portant avec hans erni symons
alors qu'il fait pas son année
et qu'il est toujours en vie school des
rugbys séparé il ya des ces gens là se
sont quand même fait drafté alors qu'ils
arrivaient et qu'on se pouvait se poser
des questions sur le contexte est sûre
pas pourquoi ils sont là alors qu'il
pourrait aller aux initiés c'est clair
je pense que si la promesse il va rester
bien sûr c'est dans son intérêt je pense
par contre que
son profil peut intéresser des
franchises qui draft des profils
différents et moi je pense que si on
veut qu'ils doivent déjà bien au kiss-in
drafté avec un sceptique mais vont
peut-être arrêter un moment qui cite
rester des joueurs casino et ça fait 3
de rap de suite qu'ils ont pas trop foot
est un genre initié donc par rapport
très mal mais donc au premier tour donc
guider et compagnie donc j'ai pas en
fait je pense que l'argument de la
jeunesse de l'inconnu font qu' il peut
avoir sa place puisque il peut plus
attiré que des joueurs que les équipes
pourvu 3,4 en collège qui le connaissent
et qu'elles ne doivent se dire bon je
sais ce que je peux acheter que ce jour
là mais a peut-être que miller a je peux
un peu le
le modelé différemment par contre ce qui
est sûr c'est que moi c'est siliva 7 j
league l'année prochaine à nouveau
contrairement à sharp qui aura des
minutes surtout s'il est drafté top 10
tomas as tu des choses a ajouté sur
léonard millaire non non je pense que
tout att tout a été dit franchement trop
de potentiel pour moi pour ne pas
forcément être pris au prometteur sané
s'il a pas de promesses pour moi faut
attendait il y est ré ou l'année
prochaine car le conflit est trop
intrigant la combinaison taille de shoot
ne pouvoir poser la balle de vitesse de
qualités athlétiques donc pour moi trop
intéressant que si c'est pas cette année
sera l'année prochaine et
potentiellement très au parfum très
bonne conclusion léonard miller le
canadien allait voir sa fiche et celle
de shannon sharpe sur envergure points
c'est au des milliers de fiches de
joueurs tous nos podcasts nos toutes nos
vidéos alesi abonnez-vous sur la
plateforme d' écoute que soit deezer
spotify ou autres sur youtube aussi sur
twitch et si ce qu'on fait vous plaît en
tout cas n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
thomas merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous merci
à vous de l'invitation ça fait plaisir
et bravo pour ton taf a retrouvé donc
sur twitter à z cas mais tu as aussi une
chaîne youtube avec des scouting report
en vidéo exactement dans la description
de twitter voilà c'est carré ses frais
merci à toi thomas et manu banal en
continu le taf moins jusqu'à la draft on
vous retrouve très bientôt et on vous
fait tous des bisous